all I wanted was a much-deserved
promotion and he told me to get up on
the desk and spread him all the men in
my office wrote down on a piece of paper
the sexual favors that I could do for
them all I had asked for was an office
with a window I asked for his advice
about how I could get a bill out of
committee he asked me if I brought my
kneepads those are just a few of the
horrific stories that I heard from women
over the last year as I've been
investigating workplace sexual
harassment and what I found out is that
it's an epidemic across the world it's a
horrifying reality for millions of women
when all they want to do every day is go
to work sexual harassment doesn't
discriminate you can wear a skirt
hospital scrubs army fatigues you can be
younger old married or single black or
white you can be a Republican a Democrat
or an independent I heard from so many
women police officers members of our
military financial assistance actors
engineers lawyers bankers accountants
teachers journalists sexual harassment
it turns out is not about sex it's about
power and about what somebody does to
you to try and take away your power and
I'm here today to encourage you to know
that you can take that power back
on July 6 2016
I jumped off a cliff all by myself it
was the scariest moment of my life an
excruciating choice to make I fell into
an abyss all alone not knowing what
would be below but then something
miraculous started to happen thousands
of women started reaching out to me to
share their own stories of pain and
agony and shame they told me that I
became their voice they were voiceless
and suddenly I realized that even in the
21st century
every woman still has a story like Joyce
a flight attendant supervisor who's boss
in meetings every day would tell her
about the porn that he'd watched the
night before while drawing penises on
his notepad
she went to complain she was called
crazy and fired like Joann Wall Street
banker her male colleagues would call
her that vile c-word every day she
complained labeled a troublemaker never
to do another Wall Street deal again
like Elizabeth an army officer her male
subordinates would waive $1 bills in her
face and say dance for me and when she
went to complain to a major he said what
only $1 you're worth at least five or
ten after reading replying to all and
crying over all of these emails I
realized I had so much work to do
here are the startling facts one in
three women that we know of have been
sexually harassed in the workplace 71%
of those incidences never get reported
why because when women come forward
they're still called liars and
troublemakers and demeaned and trashed
and demoted and blacklisted and fired
reporting sexual harassment can be in
many cases career-ending of all the
women that reached out to me almost none
are still today working in their chosen
profession and that is outrageous
I too was silent in the beginning it
happened to me at the end of my year as
Miss America when I was meeting with a
very high-ranking TV executive in New
York City I thought he was helping me
throughout the day making a lot of phone
calls we went to dinner and in the back
seat of a car
he suddenly lunged on top of me and
stuck his tongue down my throat I didn't
realize that to get into the business
silly me
he also intended to get into my pants
and just a week later when I was in Los
Angeles meeting with a high-ranking
publicist it happened again again in a
car and he took my neck in his hand and
he shoved my head so hard into his
crotch I couldn't breathe these are the
events that suck the life out of all of
your self-confidence these are the
events that until recently I didn't even
call assault and this is why we have so
much work to do after my years Miss
America I continue to meet a lot of
well-known people including Donald Trump
when this picture was taken in 1988
nobody could have ever predicted where
we'd be today me fighting to end sexual
harassment in the workplace he president
of the United States in spite of it and
shortly thereafter I got my first gig in
television news in Richmond Virginia
check out that confidence my
with the bright pink jacket not so much
the hair I was working so hard to prove
that blondes have a lot of brains but
ironically one of the first stories I
covered was the Anita Hill hearings in
Washington DC and shortly thereafter I
too was sexually harassed in the
workplace I was covering the story in
rural Virginia and when we got back into
the car my cameraman started saying to
me wondering how much I had enjoyed when
he touched my breasts when he put the
microphone on me and it went downhill
from there
I was bracing myself against the
passenger door this was before cell
phones I was petrified I actually
envisioned myself rolling outside of
that door as the car was going 50 miles
per hour like I'd seen in the movies and
wondering how much it would hurt when
the story about Harvey Weinstein came to
light one of the most well known movie
moguls in all of Hollywood the
allegations were horrific but so many
women came forward and it made me
realize what I had done meant something
[Applause]
[Music]
he had such a lame excuse he said he was
a product of the 60s and 70s and that
that was the culture then yeah that was
the culture then and unfortunately it
still is why because of all the myths
that are still associated with sexual
harassment women should just take
another job and find another career yeah
right tell that to the single mom
working two jobs trying to make ends
meet who's also being sexually harassed
women they bring it on themselves by the
clothes that we wear and the makeup that
we put on yeah I guess those hoodies
that uber engineers wear in Silicon
Valley are just so provocative women
make it up yeah because it's so fun and
rewarding to me demeaned and taken down
I would know women bring these claims
because they want to be famous and rich
our own president said that I bet Taylor
Swift one of the most well known and
richest singers in the world didn't need
more money or fame when she came forward
with her groping case for $1 and I'm so
glad she did breaking news the untold
story about women and sexual harassment
in the workplace women just want a safe
welcoming and harass free environment
that's it
[Music]
so how do we go about getting our power
back I have three solutions number one
we need to turn bystanders and enablers
into allies 98% of United States
corporations right now have sexual
harassment training policies 70% have
prevention programs but still
overwhelmingly bystanders and witnesses
don't come forward in 2016 the Harvard
Business Review called it the bystander
effect and yet remember 9/11 millions of
times we've heard if you see something
say something
imagine how impactful that would be if
we carried that through to bystanders in
the workplace regarding sexual
harassment to recognize and interrupt
these incidences to confront the
perpetrators to their face to help and
protect the victims this is my shout out
to men we need you in this fight and to
women to enablers to allies number two
change the laws how many of you out
there know whether or not you have a
forced arbitration clause in your
employment contract not a lot of hands
and if you don't know you should and
here's why Time magazine calls it right
there on the screen the teeny tiny
little print in contracts that keeps
sexual harassment claims unheard here's
what it is
forced arbitration takes away your
Seventh Amendment right to an open jury
process it's secret you don't get the
same witnesses or depositions in many
cases the company picks the arbitrator
for you there are no Appeals and only
20% of the time does the employee win
but again its secrets so nobody ever
knows what happened to you this is why
I've been working so diligently on
Capitol Hill in Washington DC to change
the laws and here's what I
the Senators sexual harassment is a
political before somebody harasses you
they don't ask you if you're a
Republican or Democrat first they just
do it and this is why we should all care
number three be fierce it starts when we
stand tall and we build that
self-confidence and we stand up and we
speak up and we tell the world what
happened to us I know it's scary but
let's do it for our kids
let's stop this for the next generations
I know that I did it for my children
they were paramount in my
decision-making about whether or not I
would come forward my beautiful children
my twelve-year-old son Christian my
fourteen-year-old daughter Kaia and boy
did I underestimate them the first day
of school last year happened to be the
day my resolution was announced and I
was so anxious about what they would
face and my daughter came home from
school and she said mommy so many people
asked me what happened to you over the
summer and then she looked at me in the
eyes and she said and mommy I was so
proud to say that you were my mom and
two weeks later when she finally found
the courage to stand up to two kids
who'd been making her life miserable she
came home to me and she said mommy I
found the courage to do it because I saw
you do it
you see giving the gift of courage is
contagious and I hope that my journey
has inspired you because right now it's
the tipping point we are watching
history happen more and more women are
coming forward and saying enough is
enough here's my one last plea to
companies let's hire back all those
women whose careers were lost because of
some random jerk because here's what I
know about women we will no longer be
underestimated intimidated or setback we
will not be silenced by the ways of the
establishment or the relics of the past
no we will stand up and speak up and
have our voices heard we will be the
women we were meant to be and above all
we will always be fierce thank you
[Music]